alright remember the vindication I've
been telling you is coming tonight it is
in full motion everything that we have
been reporting for over the past year
and the media has ignored for the past
year is now being uncovered we have so
much information
I literally need three hours tonight
we'll go through it slowly so everybody
gets it now please stay with us it will
take your breath away the Attorney
General jeff Sessions is revealing that
there are in fact more than 50 thousand
text messages between Trump hating FBI
employees Peter struck and Lisa page
this is significant because previous
reporting put the number of text
messages at only 10,000 and sessions is
also vowing tonight to get to the bottom
of the missing text messages which
beginning to look more and more like an
FBI cover-up this is a massive
developing scandal and it ties into
everything we have been telling you now
we're learning that five five months of
text messages between the Trump hating
lover struck in page they have
conveniently disappeared I don't make
this up the messages that the FBI is
claiming to have lost well they are from
a critical crucial time in the Russia
investigation now here's what happened
during that five months this is from
December 14 2016
- May 17 2017 March 4th President Trump
claimed that he was wiretap at Trump
Tower we don't have the exchanges from
them I'd love to know what struck and
page when Qasim being about at that
point January 11th remember BuzzFeed
they published the Clinton bought and
paid for phony Russian propaganda
dossier that the FBI then used to help
get a FISA warrant against the Trump
campaign they say against Carter page
that was a pretext January 24th now
former national security adviser
Lieutenant General Michael Flynn he's
interviewed by the FBI and a hopeful ins
attorneys are watching tonight because
it was one person in the room named
Peter struck who has made it clear that
he despises all things Donald Trump he
oversaw that interview now given what we
now know you have to wonder how fair
could struck possibly be now how struck
had no business being involved in that
investigation or any of the others that
he's involved in the guy still
shouldn't have a job as I said last
Friday he should be fired he should in
fact be investigated then we go to May
9th
FBI director James Comey is fired may
17th Robert Muller is named special
counsel so the messages are missing from
that entire time period the most
critical time but they're available from
May 18th that's the exact day after
Robert Muller was appointed special
counsel you don't think that's highly
suspicious now struck in Page they are
the key players in everything that we
have been uncovering they got their
hands at everything are we really
supposed to believe that the FBI simply
lost text messages from that important
time frame this is like Watergate and
far worse remember the 18 and a half
minute gap in the White House tapes this
reeks of law-breaking it reeks of
conspiracy and it reeks of obstruction
of justice and by the way the cover-up
is always worse than the crime now
that's what it looks like to me tonight
now the DOJ they're trying to explain it
away they are saying tonight that many
of the FBI's issued Samsung five phones
didn't capture text messages during that
period hold on a second we're gonna
blame Samsung the DOJ is you know
chalking this up to a quote myth
configuration on issues related to
rollouts provisioning and software
upgrades that conflicted with the FBI's
collection capabilities we're gonna
blame Samsung they're blaming Samsung
where are the phones tonight and instead
of making excuses
the FBI have you brought in your best
forensic experts to analyze the phones
and by the way if you can't get the
messages you need to call Samsung maybe
they'll help you and if the FBI doesn't
want to do that then we can only draw
the conclusion that the FBI clearly is
hiding something in this very crucial
time period and time line that we're
talking about remember Lois Lerner no
she's another example now this is part
of a much larger pattern here let's look
at Hillary Clinton's email server
scandal remember 33000 deleted emails
that had been subpoenaed by Congress now
to make doubly sure that those were
erased never to be retrieved again
well then Clinton
said wash the hard drives with a item
known as bleach fit to get rid of all of
them no trace of them while those emails
again under congressional subpoena and
on top of that a Clinton aide then took
the BlackBerry's and mobile devices and
smashed them with a hammer and the few
remaining cell phones
well they turn over to the FBI they had
no SIM cards and look at these headlines
Fox News October 2016 quote FBI agreed
to destroy laptops of Clinton aides with
immunity deal lawmaker says well why
would the FBI ever agree to destroy
evidence that doesn't make sense and
according to the same reporting as part
of the plea deal the FBI wasn't allowed
to search emails after the existence of
Clinton's server was made public which
means that the FBI wouldn't be able to
look at possible obstruction of justice
by Clinton and her aides when it's so
obvious that's what happened then
there's this October 5th the report from
the Washington Examiner quote immunity
deals stopped FBI from investigating
bleach pit use in Clinton email case any
of you at home ever used bleach pit you
ever smashed your mobile devices Clinton
destroyed evidence and the FBI didn't
even want to investigate and we can't
forget instead of coming clean and
admitting what she was doing Hillary
Clinton gave excuse after excuse after
excuse for using an unsecure email
server at a mom-and-pop shop after him
closet remember five foreign
intelligence agencies got access to all
of this take a look the laws and
regulations in effect when I was
Secretary of State
allowed me to use my email for work that
is undisputed it clearly wasn't the best
choice and I take responsibility for
that decision I thought it would be
easier to carry just one device for my
work and for my personal emails instead
of two iPhone or Android iPhone
okay in full disclosure blackberry and a
blackberry I have a you know an iPad a
mini iPad an iPhone and a blackberry
what like with a cloth or something no
well no by the way you may have seen
that I recently launched a snapchat
account those messages disappear all by
themselves really gonna joke about a
Clinton broke the law
we know she certainly didn't take care
of classified top secret special access
information she destroyed such and by
the way and it's pretty simple that the
FBI let her off the hook we'll have more
on that in just a second tonight we have
new information this destruction of
evidence is part of a pattern from the
Obama administration remember Lois
Lerner IRS targeting conservative
scandal the agency lost the emails of
Lois Lerner and the official that was
leading the charge in unfairly going
after conservatives the IRS said the
emails were lost because of a system
crash every time the walls are closing
in on the Obama administration officials
key evidence just disappears and they
found a two years later in that case
when it keeps happening it's not a
coincidence it's actually called
obstruction of justice and there are
also several other wrinkles in this
story
there's also remember Debbie
wasserman-schultz the it8 scandal well
he had smashed hard drives at his garage
but of course the aides lawyer denied it
ever happened also breaking tonight a
newly released text message from Peter
struck and Lisa Paige this is where it
gets interesting appears to now show
that both of them and now tonight add
the Attorney General former attorney
general Loretta Lynch knew that Hillary
Clinton would not be prosecuted in her
email server investigation
what's important is they're saying this
before they ever interviewed Hillary now
before we show you the message let's
give you a little the backstory remember
in May call me and struck and other top
FBI officials remember they were
drafting the Clinton exoneration on the
email server scandal before ever
interviewing Hillary and 17 other key
witnesses so exoneration before
investigation yeah that's called being
rigged in the
was in and then you also have former
attorney general Loretta Lynch meeting
who bill clinton on a tarmac talking
about grandchildren for forty minutes at
the end of june again they still have
not interrogated or or ask questions of
hillary clinton and the key people in
this investigation Lynch also called
Comey member had the meeting with Comey
and said to Comey
call it a matter not an investigation
and call me followed her orders to the
letter
and then just days later when Lynch said
that she would step away from the email
investigation she said she would accept
the FBI's conclusion well struck test
texted page underlie first look at this
timing looks like hell page responds
yeah that is awful timing talking about
the tarmac meeting it's a real Profile
in Courage since Sheila Retta Lynch
knows no charges will be brought how did
she know now four days after that Comey
held his press conference
letting Hillary Clinton off the hook now
we also have the text message between
struck and page remember talking about
the insurance policy and case god forbid
Donald Trump became president the fix
was in this was rigged this was an
exoneration without an investigation
there's no equal justice under the law
here he got struck Paige Lynch all new
the charges would not be recommended
against Clinton that's why they wrote
the exoneration early on and if Lisa
Paige knew then that means that her boss
the deputy FBI director Andrew McCabe
knew who we think struck and Paige were
talking to in the insurance quote text
message and that would probably meet the
new that Clinton would go free now we
also need to know you know what now
Deputy Attorney General what a rotten
Rosenstein no and when did he know it he
has a lot of questions to start
answering and if Comey and Lynch the top
two law enforcement officials in the
country knew and I gather there's a
pretty good chance that someone in the
Obama White House also knew the fix was
in for Hillary
the timing is key if you put the fix and
she gets to stay in the presidential
race if she gets indicted the Democratic
Party is thrown into shambles before an
important presidential election they
thought they knew better
and they saved Hillary because they
thought she would win and they wanted to
appoint her the President of the United
States do you think Watergate was a big
scandal
this is Watergate on steroids and human
growth hormones at levels that would
kill the average person and to top it
all off there's even more information
tonight
another newly released text message
between struck and page it talks about a
change to commis clinton exoneration
letter now the statement originally
referenced clinton emailing president
obama when she was quote on the
territory of a hostile country now the
part mentioning obama was then altered
to say a quote senior government
official before being removed entirely
so obama had to know that clinton was
using a private email server and we have
the evidence tonight and we also have
new breaking developments in terms of
republicans effort to release the
classified four-page memo that details
these massive FISA abuses against the
trump campaign
this is becoming the biggest scandal in
american history modern american history
you have members of congress who have
seen it are saying the contents are
shocking jaw-dropping alarming people
will go to jail and Fox News is
reporting tonight that releasing the
memo to you the American people could
take up to 19 congressional business
days if all the procedures are quote
followed that means we don't get to see
the memo you don't get to see the memo
until at least the middle of March
tonight we are asking that you keep
applying pressure demand that the public
see the memo release the memo you need
to see the truth you need to know about
this massive abuse of power
they are trampling on our Constitution
they're shredding it our Fourth
Amendment rights against unreasonable
search and seizure the weaponization of
our intelligence community and how the
clinton bought and paid for phony
Russian dossier she fixed remember she
fixed the primary she had Comey struck
and apparently Loretta Lynch trying to
fix her case when she broke the law then
she tried to use the pony dossier to fix
a general election why not after worked
in the primary and then they use it in
an effort to spy on an opposition
candidate in an election
here and then a president-elect and his
team call the number at the bottom of
the screen we need to see this memo 202
two to four 31 21 we'll put it up
throughout the evening tell you remember
of Congress released the memo there's a
ton of information tonight let's let me
sum up what this all means
Clinton fixed the primary against Bernie
struck called me and apparently Loretta
Lynch then exonerated Hillary without
ever interviewing her the key people in
that whole email server scandal the fix
was in it was rigged Clinton and the DNC
tried to influence the general they
bought and paid for Russian lies before
an election and the fix was in there and
the Obama administration weaponized the
powerful tools of intelligence the
target members of the Trump campaign the
fix was in struck in his mistress Lisa
Paige talked about an insurance policy
and now key text messages are missing
the fix is it this is far worse than
Watergate it's a massive abuse of power
and you are witnessing one of the
biggest scandals in American history
with a cover-up to boot key players
struck Paige Bruce or Rod Rosenstein
need to be fired and investigated Comey
Loretta Lynch investigated and I'm not
talking about rank-and-file members in
the FBI in Justice Department that do
great work or in the intelligence
community I'm talking specifically about
abuses committed by the very top
officials in the deep state in the FBI
and the Department of Justice and of
Robert Muller you're watching tonight
and I'm sure you are and I'm sure your
your corrupt team of Obama Hillary
Clinton deep state witch hunters are
watching this witch hunt needs to be
shut down since you've clearly stacked
the deck against and started out with a
biased investigation against President
Trump and finally tonight the government
shuts down is over the president just
signed a temporary bill and I told you
was no big deal all the panic by the
rest of the media was a waste of your
time